People have a lot of guilt,
you know,
there there's a line of social
psychology that claims that most people
feel that they're better than other
people and like I just don't buy that,
that isn't what I've seen in my life and
maybe I'm a bit biased because I'm a
clinical psychologist and I see more
people who are overtly suffering maybe
than people do in general.
Although I'm not so sure about that,
you know,
because you don't have to scratch very
far beneath the surface of most people's
lives before you find something truly
tragic.
And I don't mean this sort of tragedy
that you whine about.
I mean,
you know,
your mother has Alzheimer's or,
or your,
your best friend committed suicide or
you have a close relative with cancer.
You have a sick child or you know,
there's something wrong with you because
almost everyone has at least one really
terrible thing wrong with them.
And if you don't,
hey you will.
So,
you know,
so that,
so,
that depth tragic sense of being is
there with people all the time.
And it's also the case that,
that in my experience,
like I rarely meet someone who says,
Hey,
you know,
I'm doing everything I possibly can.
I'm a hell of a guy and I can't see how
I could possibly improve.
You know,
you meet,
you meet someone like that.
You think they're narcissistic,
right?
Would endure,
right.
And,
but,
but most people don't feel that way.
They feel like they could do a hell of a
lot better than they are and they're
quite acutely aware of their faults and
they don't feel that they are what they
should be.
And you see what happens in the story of
Adam and Eve as well as that.
When people become self conscious,
at least that's how it looks to me.
They get thrown out of paradise and then
they're in history.
And history is a place where there's
pain in childbirth and where you're
dominated by your mate and where you
have to toil like mad,
like no other animal because you're
aware of the future.
You have to work and sacrifice the joys
of the present for the future
constantly.
And you know you're going to die and you
have all that weight on you.
And to me,
again,
that's just how can anything be more
true than not.
That's just as far as I can tell.
That's just how it is for.
Unless you're naive beyond
comprehension,
there's something about your life that,
that,
that is echoed in,
in that representation and why it is
that mean we're such strange creatures
because we don't seem to really fit into
being in some sense.
And that's also what's expressed in the
notion of the fall.
We,
the existentialist said,
well,
people feel like they have a debt that
they have to pay off to existence for
the,
for the crime of there,
for the crime of there being something
like that.
And maybe it's because we're acutely
aware that we have to offer something of
value to the people around us so that
they can tolerate us.
You know,
well we're,
we're going about our business.
But it seems deeper than that is that
human beings seem to exist in a post
cataclysmic world.
And that's exactly also what's
represented in genesis.
And it's very interesting because you
know,
there's,
in the Adam and Eve story,
there's two,
there's two catastrophes.
Essentially there's the catastrophe that
occurs when Adam and eve wake up,
which we'll talk about in detail and
become self conscious and,
and know that they're naked,
that and their eyes are open,
right?
So that's the terminology that's used.
And to have your eyes open means to have
an,
an increment in consciousness.
Essentially [inaudible] eyes are
associated with consciousness for human
beings because we're intensely visual
animals.
And so the metaphor of having your eyes
opened means it's the same as the
metaphor of coming to consciousness.
And as soon as Adam and eve come to
consciousness,
they realized they're naked.
And you know,
the classic interpretation of that is
that it has something to do with sexual
sin.
And I don't,
I don't believe that I,
I don't believe that that's what it
means.
All the other elements about that that
are irrelevant,
it's more of that to realize that you're
naked.
It's like you're,
you know,
if you dream that you're naked on a
stage in front of people,
that's not a sexual dream man.
Unless you're some kind of strange
exhibitionist,
right?
It's,
it's you want to cover yourself up and
get the hell off that stage as fast as
possible and so it'll be naked in front
of a crowd is to have everyone.
It's to have the judgment of the social
world focused on your self evident
inadequacies and that makes people self
conscious and that that's a real human
state.
It's associated with neuroticism and in
the big five traits model,
but people don't like that at all.
They don't like having their fragility
and vulnerability exposed to the group.
It's one of the two major fears of
people because one is social humiliation
and the other is something like
mortality and death and like your.
Your typical agoraphobic for example,
gets to have both those fears at the
same time because she usually is.
She Ken's to believe she's going to have
a very spectacular and exhibition mystic
heart attack in a public place and make
a terrible fool of herself while she's
dying.
So,
and then that's a good example of the
two archetipal fears that characterize,
characterize human beings.